dude you want to crash the mall you've
always been a fashion icon can i show
you a few pictures and just get some
quick reaction from you just from some
of your looks from over the years is
that okay
take off all your preppy clothes let's
start with the classic right here
i love me a baggy camo pants
and then like put a canadian flag on my
tie this was the mtv awards probably
back in like 2002 or something
classic my first year at the grammys
i was like i'm not wearing a dress i
want to wear a tuxedo and then decked it
out and kind of made it my own
this is one of my favorites i love that
cool
that was a i heart radio festival in las
vegas and that was my stage outfit yeah
and i like to like put like half of my
head up and braids sometimes so
i was experimenting with that i'll say
one of the things that you've always had
is when you look at you on a red carpet
you always look like you're dressed for
fun you know what i mean even in
something like that right
yeah
yeah i love that outfit pink is one of
my favorite colors
same same yeah
[Music]